Hi, everyone.
In this lesson, we're going to look
at our other layered approach when it comes
to materials in Unreal.
So let's get started.
You'll see an example that I have here set up,
one with a more complex layered material set up,
and one that's a bit more simplistic.
Let's open up those materials for a second
and talk about them.
So if we bring this over into our scene, there we go.
We'll see that we have several different layers
to think about.
Now, these ones up here, you can play with them if you want to.
I'm going to go ahead and kill these particular materials
here because we don't really need them.
These two in particular, I'll leave the last one
because that's the one we're working with.
So this one I'll get rid of and this one.
So what I created here was a layered system
in which we used a thing called a material layer.
And we created two of those.
We created one material layer and another one,
one for like the tiling and one for like some sort of crunch.
From there, we created a material layer blend.
And then we also created a parent material
where all of these will be housed.
Now, if you're familiar with curves
when it comes to Unreal, say we're
going to make that real quick.
Let me move this over just for a second.
When you create a curve, you can simply go in here
and we'll go to our in class materials.
And when you make a curve, the curve atlas
allows you to be able to house information.
Now, you can simply just type in curve here.
And you'll see that there's a curve and a curve atlas.
This material layer blend works kind of like a curve atlas
where the curve information or in this case,
the layer information is going to be housed.
That's kind of how that works.
And finally, the parent material will have
all the information we need.
Now, at any time you get lost or you
want to know more about these materials,
feel free to go into the folder where they live.
And you can see I'm hitting the magnifying glass.
And you can see all the different ones
that I have created.
We can easily double click these materials.
And you can see what we have set up.
Now, to speed things up, I want
to be copy pasting my examples because you should
know already how to set up a material in general
and get this in the right direction.
We're also going to copy paste anything
that we have in such things as our material layer blend.
And we can copy paste those and build them out.
But our final output, if we look in our directory,
is going to be that master material.
And in this parent material, we're
going to house all of the information.
And we're going to be using the material layer node
to be able to house the things that we need,
kind of like that curve atlas.
That's kind of how that works.
So if you're not familiar with the curve atlas,
bear with me.
I just want to make sure you had something to possibly relate
to if you're familiar with them.
So this parent material is having this material attribute
layer.
And in here, we have, as you can see,
I have it broken down here, two different layers.
We have a background and we have a foreground.
And it's really up to you how you want to shuffle these.
Typically, this is our tiling here.
And then this one is our grunge that we're
going to push through.
I just have it as the background in this case.
But again, you can mix and match these as you will.
So let me go and move this over for a second here.
And let's go ahead and build this out.
And you'll get an idea of what we're going for.
And at any time, you can open up those samples.
So I'm going to go back into our material folder,
go to in class mat.
We can go ahead and if you have an in class folder
already, go ahead and make one.
I have one already set up.
And we can just, if we keep things less confusing,
we can simply go in here and make a new folder.
Or you can start building your materials.
But if you do, make sure you put new on the end of it.
You'll see that I already have a new grunge.
I'm going to go ahead and delete him for now
so that we can start from a clean slate.
And I'll go ahead and make a folder for us.
And we'll call this new in class.
So I'm going to go ahead and right click in here.
And I'm going to go to material.
But I'm going to go to the layers area.
I'm going to create a material layer.
And we'll call this mlgrunge.
And I'll put an underscore here.
And let me make sure it takes, there we go, underscore grunge.
Actually, that's too new.
So we don't mix up with any existing samples.
And then we'll do another one.
Right click, we're going to go to materials.
We're going to go to our material layers.
And in here, we'll create another material layer.
And we'll call this ml for material layer.
And that makes it easier for you to quickly view it.
It will be posted on the bottom here, you'll see it.
So material layer, we'll call this wall
or new wall, I should say, new wall.
There we go right there and hit enter.
With those two created, we're now going to go ahead
and make a material layer blend.
So we'll go back up into materials
and we'll go to the layer section.
And we'll create a material layer blend.
You have the option also to make instances ahead of time.
But we're just going to focus on the primaries
and then you can explore that on your own,
since the concept of instances
has been covered in other classes.
So let's go and grab that material layer blend.
And we'll call it mlb underscore new,
underscore dirt sample.
And we can do samp for now.
There we go.
And then finally, we want to make a parent material,
which is going to house all of this information.
So we go to materials here,
and we'll call this m underscore new,
underscore layer sample.
There you go.
Awesome, I got a capital A there, that's fine.
So let's go ahead and open these up
and we'll keep it pretty simple.
We're going to copy paste what is already existing
so you can understand the concepts.
You should know already know
how to build your materials quickly and fast.
So this will just mainly point you
to setting this particular system up.
So I'll double click on grunge here new,
and I'm going to pull him over into our scene
so we can see him.
And we're going to copy paste
the existing grunge information that we already have.
Now one of the nodes we do primarily need to set in here,
when we're building this out,
is it make material attributes.
So I'm going to right click
and do make material attributes.
There we go.
That's going to be our primary setup
to be able to connect this into here.
And then from here,
we simply just grab those simple assets
that we already have,
which is the grunge normal and the grunge albedo.
And we'll just go copy.
I'll pull this over.
And then we'll place this into place.
There we go.
And let's go and connect these.
So I'll grab the albedo,
pull that over to the base color,
and I'll grab the normal.
Now it's up to you if you want to do like a,
but multiply and you'll have like a value.
I'm just going to simply for time sake,
pull that right into the normal there.
And we should be just fine.
And I'm going to hit apply.
Now with that in place,
I'm now going ahead,
go ahead and we're going to go
to the other material we have.
And that is our new,
our new other layer that we have set up,
not our parent material,
we want to go to our wall.
Let's go to our material layer here
and pull this over.
And we'll just drag it into this set.
And then I'm going to go to the one
that I already have set up.
That's going to be our tile,
you can call it wall, tile,
whatever you want to call it.
We're going to grab this information,
copy,
and I'll move this over.
And we're going to do that make attributes again,
because then we're kind of like breaking the information
and then making that information for us.
Connect that to the preview.
And then I'm going to paste this into the scene
and pull this into the base.
And I'll grab the normal
and pull that into the normal,
keeping it fairly simple.
You'll see that we have a bit of tint.
If I want to,
I can expose a value
and I can have it so that we have
a normal multiply if you want to.
But again, we're leaving that out.
And then again, you can totally feel free to do that.
And I'm gonna hit apply.
So next we have on slate here is our
material layer blend.
Let's open this up,
because this is where the blending is going to happen.
Let me drag him into the scene.
Now, if we look at the sample that I gave you,
you'll see that it can be pretty complex if you want it,
or super simplistic.
In this particular case,
we're going to go ahead and grab some of this grunge
information.
And if I pull this over,
you'll see there's a simple grunge roughness.
And I can use that as my filter for my dirt.
And that's kind of what we're going to do.
So let's go ahead and grab that information.
And we're going to apply it into our scene.
And we're going to bring that into the alpha.
So I'm going to grab all of this.
And I'm going to hit command C.
And I'm going to go back into the one
that we've established for our sample,
go full screen,
move this over just for a second.
And then I'm going to hit control V.
Now with that set up,
we're going to go ahead and we need a couple of things.
Because we have these two guys,
we need to arrange some things, I should say.
We need to pull these guys up,
so it's a little bit clearer to see,
so you can see where I'm going.
And we need to now connect this into this alpha.
Now you'll notice when we do this,
there's not a whole lot going on, right?
You won't necessarily see a preview.
That's fine.
We will see it later on the backend.
And I'm going to hit apply.
And that's really all we need for these three items.
So again, the key ones,
I'm going to remind you of this
because it's really important to remember,
we have a material layer one,
which could be our base or our dirt,
depending on what you want.
And material layer two,
which again could be our base or dirt,
depending on what you want to push through.
And then finally, we have a material layer blend,
which is going to allow us to control
how that's going to be blended.
You can control, you can have intensity or contrast.
On here, you'll notice I have a multiply set in here.
We're using the green channel,
we just want it to push through
to just to be used as an alpha.
So there's no direct color information we're worried about,
because it's going to be referencing
what we already have in place.
And then we have a power to control
how strong that's coming through via
and that's why we call it contrast.
We bring it into a clamp so it's within a range,
and we bring that into the alpha.
All right, so finally,
like that Atlas concept I told you about,
we need to bring it into our parent material.
I'm gonna double click on this parent material,
pull him over into our scene,
and now we're going to arrange this guy
the way that we need.
So one of the first things we want to do
is use material attributes.
So let's collapse that node.
So this is our final node setup.
We want to have a material attributes layer.
So material, attributes, make sure it's right,
and we want layer.
And you'll see that attributes layers,
I should say layers is right here.
And it should be not attributes but attribute there
just so that we're clear.
There we go.
Now with this set in, I'm going to drag this over to here,
and we're gonna build out our nodes.
So you'll notice we have a background.
I'm gonna click on this plus here.
This is gonna be our layer one,
and then we have our background.
Now if you want, you can go in here
and pull them into your scene
because we've already built them.
So I'm gonna go in here and say,
hey, I need my background,
and I can determine say my, or my layer,
my first layer, you could say,
hey, I want this to be the tile,
so I want the tiles to push through.
You're gonna get an error
because we need that blend asset.
So let's drag the blend asset in there, right there.
And then you're gonna say,
hey, you know what, I need a background
or a kind of a reference area
that we could use for our alpha,
which has been established and built into our blend.
And we can pull this grunge.
And so we're not using them yet,
but we'll put them in there.
Now if you want to, you can flip these,
it just depends on what you wanna push through.
Do you wanna push through the brick
or do you wanna push through the dirt?
It's up to you.
And you can determine even in your blend
how or how strong or what order you wanna do things.
That's when we hit apply.
Now we're gonna go to this parent material
and we're gonna right click.
I'm gonna go to asset actions.
Actually, I should correct myself there.
We're gonna go to create material instance.
We're not gonna migrate, we don't need to.
We're gonna create material instance.
And we'll call this MI and I'll move over
and we'll get rid of that instance on the end, INST.
I'm gonna hit enter.
Now when I open this up,
you're going to notice that we have our slots available.
There's our background
and this is our layered material system.
There's our open parameters.
There's our albedo tint.
Now again, I didn't give them a group name
and you definitely can do that if you want to.
And we have scalar parameter values
and we can go in here now and we can edit these.
Let's turn these on.
Albedo tint, normal, diffuse, awesome.
With that in place, we can now switch this to a cube
and then we can actually go ahead
and blend in our material.
Here's the contrast.
There's the intensity, pretty great.
And we can make one push through more than the other.
And we can add if we want to, we can do a color.
That's our albedo tint, if you haven't turned that on.
Accidentally turned mine off.
And there you go.
You got the dirt distinguished from the actual look.
We can look at the intensity of our background.
We can look at the contrast between our grunge
and we can fade things accordingly.
And again, more parameters can be set in
as you build this out,
but it shows you a bit of the layering process.
Well, that's it with this one.
In the next video, we're going to take a deeper dive
into another way to layer things
using our motion design materials.
Thanks again.